ان القوات الروسيه واصله التقدم في مخموت
وفي المناطق المحيطه بها وارفق المعهد في
تقريره اليومي صورا من شركه ماكسار عبر
الاقمار الصناعيه وخرائط ميدانيه تشير الى
ان قوه الروسيه قد تقدمت اكثر في وسط
مدينه
الروسيه وصل الى قرابه ثلاثه كيلومترات
جنوب طريق السريع الرابط بين باخموت
وتشيزكا من الجهه الجنوبيه الغربيه
للمدينه
هذا واعره سلطه القرم المواليه لروسيا
اسقاط صاروخ اطلق من الجانب الاوكراني على
مدينه على الساحل الشرقي لشبه الجزيره
واضاف موقع العسكري الروسيه ان الهجوم لم
يخلف اي ضحايا ورجح الموقع ان يكون
الصاروخ قد اطلق من منظومه للصواريخ في
منطقه تيزلي على بعد اكثر من 400 كم
منوسيا واشار الموقع الى ان السلطات
الاوكرانيه تكثف من استعداداتها لهجوم قد
يبدا في غضون اسبوعين
واعلنا مقر تنسيق بين الادارات الروسيه في
اوكرانيا ان كيا تستعد لتنفيذ ما سماه
استفزازا واسع النطاق يهدف الى تشويه سبعه
روسيا على الساحه الدوليه واضاف ان
الاستفزاز يحاكي استخدام الجيش الروسي
ذخيره كيميائيه في مقاطعه سومي وذلك بهدف
صرف انظار العالم عن جرائم نازي قوات كييف
حسب تعبيره
وذكر المقرنه تم نقل مواد سامه الى
المنطقه